Uh, my name is Suchi and I am a virtual
assistant. Uh, I have
>> virtual assistant.
>> Virtual assistant.
>> Okay. I have a question. These days we
see so much media around us, social
media, movies and sad news especially
about Gaza. How can we protect our
hearts and stay spiritually strong to
reach Kun Salim in a world full of noise
and pain? Thank you
>> sister. The question that we see so much
on media, social media, about videos
about Gaza. How can we keep a Kalbe
Salim? Sister, you have to come to my
talk. I'm giving a talk on the 20th of
July in Jakarta. 15point action plan for
the Muslim Ummah for the Palestinian
cause. So it's a long talk.
>> Okay. So I invite you and invite the
other brothers and sisters a very
important topic 15point action plan
for the Muslim Ummah as far as the
pestan cause is concerned. Hope they
answer the question. Hey,